[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis wels
heute gibt's einen kuchen ich glaub das
wird der kuchen für marcel ein richtig
schokoladiger schokoladenkuchen double
chocolate den kuchen nennt man auch ganz
gerne death by chocolate cake also ich
finde der name der sagt schon alles der
kuchen wird schokolade ich dann kommt
noch eine schokoladencreme obendrauf
also wirklich was für schoko fans und
schoko liebhaber ich werde gleich den
kuchen mit etwas kaffee zubereiten falls
ihr den kaffee aber nicht wollt weil ihr
den geschmack nicht mögt dann könnt ihr
den durch milch austauschen ihr könnt
auch ein guinness bier nehmen oder als
bier nehmen der kuchen erinnert auch so
ein bisschen an den guinness kuchen den
ich schon mal gemacht habe ihr könnt
eine limonade auch verwenden also ihr
könnt ruhig die flüssigkeit austauschen
auch durch butter milch und könnte somit
dann den kuchen eben ein bisschen anders
gestalten darf er nämlich 300 milliliter
heißen kaffee 250 g weiche butter 200
grad bitterschokolade da nehme ich immer
ganz gern die callebaut
220 gramm zucker etwas salz 3 eier ich
habe ich etwas vanille extrakt 250 gramm
mehl und zwei teelöffel backpulver oder
ihr nehmt einfach backen und 40 gramm
cacau war das erste was jetzt macht der
kaffee ist ja schon heiß und wenn jetzt
eine andere flüssigkeit nimmt dann
solltet ihr die einfach erwärmen damit
die schokolade schmelzen kann jetzt dem
ich zuerst die schokolade in eine
schüssel max mitmachen samira
wird dann kannst du den heißen kaffee
darüber gießen
scheint schnell darüber gießen wird die
schokolade gleich schmerzt
so jetzt ist absurd
ich will mehr und
deswegen einfach die flüssigkeit die ihr
verwendet
schön erhitzen
dann spart man sich das schmelzen im
topf oder im wasserbad
da gehen wir jetzt gleich noch die
butter dazu die schmilzt dann auch noch
in der restwärme
und ich kann so lange hier die backform
mit backpapier einschlagen die ist jetzt
bereits auf 22 cm durchmesser
eingestellt
[Musik]
zeig mal
schmerzlich ganz kommen dann stellen was
kurz auf dem herd ich glaube der kaffee
war schon zu kalt
werden solange getrödelt macht aber gar
nichts dann kann es nämlich hier aber
noch ganz kurz erwärmen
merkst du
ok ich kenne in der zwischenzeit hier
auch schon mal die eier verrühren mit
dem zucker
ihr seht ihr braucht gar keine
küchenmaschine das geht alles ohne
vanille extrakt und salz
kurz rühren ich meine da könnt ihr jetzt
gerne ein handrührgerät nehmen damit
sich das gut vermischt
aber muss nicht
nur gerade anders überlegt dollar kurses
hand
ich will schon noch ein bisschen weiß
schaumig und es dauert sonst jetzt ein
paar minuten so lange
und es ist anstrengung
genau
hatte der schneebesen den nehmen wir
nicht mal da ist hat sich nur für eiweiß
und für sahne
für ganz flüssige sachen und die sind
für rührkuchen guck mal
einstecken genau
dann darfst du noch bisschen rühren
hoppla jetzt
auf höchster stufe
perfekt ist schön jetzt ist richtig
schön
geben gibt alles in diese schlüssel rein
genau kommen dann diesmal da rein die
masse ist jetzt auch nicht mehr heißt
sehr gut dann sieben jetzt noch cacau
dazu
bestehen bleiben
[Musik]
pianist kannst du noch mehl dazugeben
mich lieben das muss man nicht sehen das
bak mail aber wenn ihr mehl habt was
kein wagnis dann auf jeden fall sieben
damit keine klümpchen bildet und jetzt
nur noch ganz vorsichtig unterrühren
denn sobald mail dazu kommt sollten
teile einfach nicht mehr lange gerührt
werden damit sie eben trotzdem schön
luftig und fluffig werden guck mal mama
so
kleine kreisbewegungen und dann mischt
sich das von innen nach außen ganz
langsam rein
trotz café ok
gehört und ihr seht schon der teig ist
relativ flüssig deswegen habe ich auch
den bug ring eingeschlagen denn ohne
backpapier wird es jetzt schon ein
bisschen auslaufen jetzt geben mit denen
einfach da rein
der ofen ist schon vorgeheizt und dann
kann der gebacken werden und während der
bauzeit werde ich gleich noch eine
garage zu beraten
wieso machst du dass du nach oben ich
streiche den immer so ein bisschen am
rand hoch dann geht auch noch
gleichmäßiger auf kommt der rest ist für
dich ich darf jeder soviel auskratzen
sonst haben die kinder nichts zum
ausstrecken der konnte den backofen und
dann zeige ich euch die gage
kritiker nach nämlich 200 gramm sahne
200 grad bitterschokolade und einen
esslöffel butter und dann gibt es noch
nass capone creme aus 250 gramm als
capone einem espresso des und 40
milliliter einer prise zimt einem
esslöffel butter zucker und etwas
vanille extrakt könnt ihr die sahne
aufkochen
ich könnte der garage übrigens auch mit
der mikrowelle zubereiten also falls die
mikrowelle habt lasst ihr die sahne
darin auftauchen was dabei auf das nicht
überkocht dann die sahne ausschalten
schokolade dazu geben
butter
geht muss kratzen mit dem willen da raus
und dann ist die nämlich fertig und kann
abgedeckt bei raumtemperatur einfach
schön akteuren nicht im kühlschrank
stellen da willst du einfach zu schnell
kalt aber ich finde es gleich um dann
geht es ein bisschen schneller
hunt sieht gut aus oder
und wer möchte könnte hier sogar noch
ein bisschen likör dazu geben dann könnt
ihr nämlich dekanat auch geschmacklich
so ein bisschen verfeinern oder
haselnuss sirup alles was ihr möchtet
dann findest jetzt kurz hier ein
dass sogar kaffee raus
das ist das geräusch
[Musik]
und für die mascarpone creme verrät ihr
einfach alles glatt in einer schüssel
und die werde ich jetzt aber gleich im
kühlschrank lagern
der kuchen ist jetzt schön abgekühlt ist
etwas weggebrochen macht nichts und
jetzt habe ich den schon auf eine
tortenplatte gesetzt und da kommt jetzt
die creme auf mal so sieht jetzt aus ich
habe jetzt schon bei zimmertemperatur
gelagert nicht im kühlschrank
damit sie nicht zu fest wird
und dann könntet ihr schön verteilen
[Musik]
und dann würde ich sagen hole ich jetzt
einen schokoladen liebhaber zum
probieren wird heute
ja
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt kurzer weg geschickt user
darf jetzt probieren hier tat nämlich
heute geburtstag
die man jetzt kommt
ja ich habe kein feuerzeug
nichtraucher
jetzt bekommt dann sänge werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
wir wünschen dir viel gesundheit und
viel glück viel spaß
[Gelächter]
auf das ist dir immer gut geht ja sehr
schön vielen vielen dank das wünschen
seitdem die politisch sind ich ist noch
schöner dass ich in jahre ein
wenn die internet empfehlen war's das
sagt jeder
ja tatsächlich also eigentlich erwarten
sie drauf bist immer instagram atommacht
aber ihr müsst diesen utah hat noch ein
echtes leben außerhalb von salis immer
genau und das genießt das bild nicht
bereit abend wird vom sofa zu sitzen und
irgendwelche storys
ja das ist auch gut so
fuhr ich die show und wenn man möchte
kann man noch die maske ohne sahne also
die espresso mascarpone noch dazu
löffeln wenn man möchte also ich mag
modell den anstieg hier und ja
ich glaube der darf sogar über nacht
noch durchziehen aber ich glaube es ist
jetzt schon saftig
achtung es ist so ein gucken wo man ein
stück ist und danach folgen des
beitritts
richtig gut
damit die kernkraft serie bin ich
traurig etage immer
mahnung flammen
[Gelächter]
unser zart letzte geht auch so
richtig gut die espresso mascarpone der
kleinen café
ist das schmeckst du denn kaffee im
kuchen nein da sind 300 milliliter
kaffee drin
in dieser sache koffein zu kriegen
sogar gleich so ginge
gar nicht mehr so kommt auch noch
schmeckt im kapitel mit meinen kaffee
hat und er ist trocken
ich hasse aber ich mag es nicht eine
kopie ist
der ist so so weit
zusammen die seite
schlussendlich war
also
nicht so glatt gestrichen ist ich würde
sagen das ist der schokokuchen
schlechthin wenn man schokolade mag ich
meine geburtstag der tatort
ist der schokokuchen schlechthin ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob das jetzt
als original death by chocolate cake
durchgehen würde aber ich glaube wenn es
ein kuchen gibt an dem man für den mann
sterben würde das wäre es daher
definitiv
super oder schokokuchen mit wahren kern
das jahr ist mir auch noch machen
es dazu ja
das machen wir auch also wenn ihr noch
einen schokokuchen mit warm und
flüssigen kern sehen wollt dann schreibt
mir gerne in die kommentare
dann mache ich das auf jeden fall
du kannst die kommentare schreiben ein
echter kommentieren
also machte mut bis zum nächsten mal das
rezept ist der hammer probiert es
einfach aus das rezept gibt es auch cds
- blog de oder in meiner app bis bald
des typs du darfst uns entscheiden ob
wir jetzt teilen oder ob du denn
natürlich kann ja klar klar unsere frau
nein mit euch und im remix daumen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]